Ryan Lizza who was was tossed out of the
media over over sexual assault
allegations though I guess they weren't
true or something cuz he's back in the
media now back in the White House
briefing room he decided he was going to
use his question for the press secretary
helin Akkineni to find out if the
President of the United States was
rooting for the Confederacy in the civil
war that happened over 150 years ago
does he believe the president believed
that it was a good thing absolutely
absurd he's proud of the United States
of America second with regard to our
statues Americans oppose tearing down
our statues there's a Harvard Harris
Poll released just last week that shows
60% of respondents said the statue
should remain and 71% said local
governments should block groups from
physically destroying the statues so he
stands on the side of preserving our
history that woman never ceases to amaze
me she has more composure I think that I
would have had in the event of that
question I think personally if Ryan
Lizza
or any other reporter were to ask me or
the President or anybody that question I
think the answer ought to be well Ryan
before I answer that question do you
still beat your wife how do I know you
can't say that how dare you well why the
question I'm asking is just as fair as
is president Trump rooting for the
Confederacy in the war that took place
150 years ago just as fair so just it's
just it's an honest question I'm not
pushing one side of the other Ryan Lizza
do you still beat your wife that I think
would be but Caylee mcenany had a little
more composure she was a little nicer to
him she said that questions ridiculous
and the president doesn't want to topple
statues then though then she twisted the
daggers she has want to do she twisted
the dagger into the New York Times
pointing out how they have no
credibility how they published a lie
after lie after lie and she got a zinger
and at the end that I just knew
love and I hope it comes true the
president is briefed on verified
intelligence and again I would just
point you back to the absolutely
irresponsible decision of the New York
Times to falsely report that he was
briefed on something that he in fact was
not briefed on and I really think that
it's time for the New York Times to step
back and ask themselves why they've been
wrong so wrong so often the New York
Times falsely claimed Paul Manafort
asked for polling data to be passed
along to Oleg Oleg Deripaska before
having to issue a correction in June of
2017 a New York Times falsely wrote all
17 Intel agencies had agreed on Russian
interference for not before having to
issue a correction that it was only for
agencies in 2017 February of that year
New York Times published a story
claiming Trump campaign aides had
repeated contacts with Russian
intelligence which even James Comey has
said was almost entirely wrong New York
Times it is inexcusable
the failed Russia reporting of the New
York Times and I think it's time that
the New York Times and also the
Washington Post hand back their
Pulitzers mic drop see ya peace out
Kaylee out love her she's just she is
just tremendous and they should hand
back their pule answers then I mean the
New York Times just won a Pulitzer for
the 16:19 project the central thesis of
which is demonstrably false and has been
proven false by many academic historians
including the supporters of the 16:19
project and the New York Times just
completely ignored that because it cut
against their narrative so they should
hand back their Pulitzers and we should
not grant them any credibility
whatsoever on American history or the
virus or anything else or anything else
the BLM the riots the Supreme Court I
mean any of these issues we should not
grant them any credibility Kaylee also
if this was this was a terrific press
briefing all all in all because one
thing she pointed out was that the
anarchists who are tearing down statues
have increasingly found themselves in
jail hello everyone
law and order are the building blocks to
the American dream but if anarchy
prevails this dream comes comes
crumbling down anarchy and our streets
is unacceptable and anger is not enough
you have a president committed to action
the DOJ has arrested over 100 an Argus
for rioting and destruction of federal
property the DOJ has also charged four
men in federal court for attempting to
tear down the statue of Andrew Jackson
in Lafayette Square this is great news
and you'll remember that the Attorney
General Bill Barr mentioned when I sat
down with him last week for the verdict
show he mentioned that these guys were
being arrested there were indictments
that were investigations more coming and
now we're beginning to see the fruit of
that President Trump was tweeting about
it so it's all happening now this is
very good news more of them should be
arrested and they should be thrown in
the can for at least ten years I think
that's that's the prison sentence for
for pulling down these sorts of statutes
[Music]
[Music]